هذه رسائل للموتى وليست مجردات طائرات
ورقيه عملاقه كما تتصورون
الابناء والاحفاد هنا تفننوا في صناعتها
والرسم عليها
ليتواصلوا مع احبائهم الراحلين
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عاده
وشعوب
في يوم الموتى بقوات
هنا ان الاحياء يتحدون مع عالم الاموات
هذا التقليد سنويه متبع منذ اكثر من قرن
ويقام تحديدا في اليوم الاول من شهر
نوفمبر
الحدث الابرز في الاحتفال بهذا اليوم هو
صناعه واطلاق العديد من الطائرات الورقيه
الضخمه التي يبلغ طولها احيانا نحو 20
مترا كما انها تحتاج الى شهور عده
للصناعتها وتلوينها وتجهيزها فهي كما
يعتبرونها تعد حلقه الوصل بين الاحياء
واسلافهم تحت الارض
تراديسيوم
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي يكتب على هذه الطائرات على
هذه الطائرات الملونه كتبت رسائل للعالم
ودعوات للسلام ونبذ الحروب ورسائل اخرى
مستوحاه من الاحداث الدوليه الجاريه اضافه
الى رسائل خاصه نقشت على قصاصات ورقيه
والحقت بالطائرات وجهت الى ارواح الموتى
لتم قمطهم على اقاربهم واصدقائهم
ومساعدتهم في حياتهم الاخره
ومؤخرا اصبح هذا الحدث مقصدا سياحيا يقبل
عليهم الناس من خارج كواتمالا لمشاهده
الطائرات الورقيه والاستمتاع بالطقوصي
المصاحبه له
انت مي وسطهم ووتشر في الملعب
كلهر اللي هنت طاسه
ما هي اغرب الطقوس المتعلقه بالموته التي
شاهدتموها في حياتكم